mais retombe économique pourrait
s'élever à 600 millions $ par année à
beyrouth de construction et à plus de 8
5 millions $ par année en france
d'obligation ce n'est pour y alors plus
de 2500 mémoires ont été déposés dans le
cadre des travaux du bureau d'audiences
publiques sur l'environnement à propos
du projet d' usine de liquéfaction de
gaz naturel énergie sa guinée le député
de jonquière va déposer demain un
mémoire au bape réclamant le rejet du
projet sylvain gaudreault est notre
invité bonsoir oui bonsoir monsieur
fillion alors dans votre mémoire auquel
on a pu avoir accès vous dites que ce
projet sera un succès si l'accord de
paris est un échec pourquoi vous dites
ça oui c'est complètement absurde la
seule manière de rentabiliser ce projet
c'est miser sur l'échec de l'accord de
paris qui sont venus en 2015 comme vous
le savez et auxquels le québec ont
contribué avant moi je je demande de la
cohérence d'abord voulu et le
gouvernement du québec vous savez tous
les scénarios tous les scénarios faite
par les grandes de film mais où les
grande agence internationale de
l'énergie prévoit que pour atteindre les
cibles prévues dans l'accord de paris de
réduction de gaz à effet de serre 37.5
pour ça pour 2030 pour le québec mais
avec un bonus de l'été pour 2050
le gaz naturel doit diminuer et les
prévisions de consommation également
prévoit une diminution importante de
consommation du gaz naturel liquéfié
mais ce petit monsieur gaudreault que si
nous on atteint nos objectifs se peut-il
que en produisant plus de gaz naturel
qu'on exporte davantage qu'on puisse
remplacer du charbon du pétrole ailleurs
dans le monde pour aider les autres à
baisser leurs émissions de gaz à effet
de serre ou ab sat social c'est la
théorie qui est vendu ou qui est
proposée par gnl au québec
mais premièrement rien de garanti les
contrats de gnl québec sont des marchés
étrangers pour faire sa substitution par
exemple d'énergie plus polluante que ce
soit le charbon par exemple ou d'autres
types d'énergie plus polluants
la compagnie
mais m la compagnie est elle-même a
affirmé que 40% de sa production de 11
millions de tonnes annuelles de gaz
naturel liquéfié irait en addition sur
les marchés l'autre élément c'est que en
mettant plus de gaz naturel liquéfié et
une énergie fossile sur les marchés sa
vie plombé la croissance des énergies
renouvelables et la compétitivité
également des renouvelables et dans
votre mémoire une autre chose que vous
dites aujourd'hui c'est qu'on s'enligne
pour le pour le saguenay-lac-saint-jean
là pour la région sur un projet qui aura
une courte vie est donc lourd passif
environnemental
pourquoi vous croyez que ça aura une
courte vie pourquoi ça pourrait pas
aller au delà de 2050 au delà du permis
prévu ben le permis prévue est de 25 ans
et on sait déjà que admettons que la
compagnie à son autorisation partir de
2026 dans les meilleurs scénarios mais
déjà partir de 2026 ou au mieux pour la
compagnie si on veut à partir de 2030 il
y aura une diminution de la consommation
de gaz donc c'est un projet qui dès son
sein des sens je dirais et face à un
marché qui est en décroissance ça veut
dire qu en 2050 donc 25 ans plus tard
c'est sûr qu'on sera vendu ailleurs en
termes d'énergies renouvelables quand on
regarde l'explosion des énergies
renouvelables qui prévu sur les marchés
internationaux que ce soit le solaire
l'éolien la géothermie même
l'hydroélectricité donc on est dans un
contexte où c'est un projet dont la mort
est déjà annoncée c'est un éléphant
blanc et moi j'en ai vu d'autres des
projets le des passifs environnementaux
dans la région de solutions de novelis
que ce soit bien fait hacker jean que ce
sol usines de pâtes et papiers de port
alfred et ce n'est pas bon pour une
région dans une période où six courts
pendant neuf ans de se retrouver déjà qu
un passif environnemental
mais qu'est ce que vous faites des
emplois qu'est ce que vous faites
je vous vois sourire parce que je sais
que c'est pas beaucoup d'emplois
permanents mais en même temps la région
s'est bâtie sur des usines sur des
industries sur l'aluminium sur la forêt
sur d'autres secteurs qui ont pu être et
et émetteurs quand même de gaz à effet
de serre est ce qu'on va pas à contre
courant de ce qui a quand même fait la
force du saguenay-lac-saint-jean mais si
tu as fait
force du saguenay lac saint jean
monsieur fillion c'est les ressources
naturelles c'est l'énergie renouvelable
on appelle l'hydroélectricité autant
pour produire de l'aluminium que pour
produire de des pâtes et papiers dans le
temps par exemple
donc il faut miser sur cette force la
planète se dirige vers les énergies
renouvelables mon ambition c'est que le
saguenay lac saint jean et le québec
soit le champion de sa et la croissance
des emplois dans l'économie verte dans
les énergies renouvelables est beaucoup
plus élevé que dans l'économie
traditionnelle et dans le créneau de
l'aluminium vous le savez comme moi que
le projet et les is kill à la découverte
du saint graal pour l'industrie de
l'aluminium dont clip une co entreprise
apple alcoa rio tinto pour produire
l'aluminium sans carbone déjà la
recherche pour pour commercialiser ce
fait dans ma circonscription à jonquière
l'objectif c'est quand ça sera prêt vert
2024 c'est que la production se fasse
chez nous l'aluminium qui est déjà le
plus vert moment mais ils sont encore
plus du saguenay-lac-saint-jean donc
l'avenir est là autour des sens que je
peux région est ce que est ce que
l'objectif aussi n'est pas celui
d'éviter l'exode des jeunes à
l'extérieur de la région charles martel
qui le député conservateur de chicoutimi
le fjord y ont fait environ 600 jeunes
par année depuis 1996 parce qu'ils
partent à l'extérieur pour l'emploi
est-ce que gnl québec ne viendrait pas
contribuer à une dynamique de création
d'emplois il a raison sur les chiffres
malheureusement de perte ou de
démographie ou de fuite des jeunes ou
deux mais la vraie solution est
certainement dans des emplois d'avenir à
long terme qui sont dans les énergies
renouvelables c'est ce qui intéresse les
jeunes et dans les économies vertes
également on à la chaire de recherche en
éco-conseil à l'uqac amis on a la chair
timbre sur les énergies renouvelables ou
cégep de jonquière qui font déjà des
projets dans ces domaines là et qui
forme les jeunes les mieux formés à
l'échelle nationale
alors moi je pense que c'est parce qu'il
faut aller pour accuser les jeunes à
long terme
parfait votre mémoire demain au bape
simon gaudreault merci merci monsieur
fillion revoir